you
[Music]
okay so excited to have Charlie woo
visit us this week
Charlie is currently a professor at the
University of Oregon but he'll move on
later this year to quick where he
accepted a new position in the computer
science department Charlie worked on an
impressive range of staff quantum
algorithms query complexity even
programming languages he also works on
and had a purple purple paper last year
Charlie got his PhD from Michigan in
2013 many of you might note Yong Chi is
advisor he was a postdoc at MIT and
refinements Research Fellow and you got
the floor Jody okay
thanks for the introduction he had also
interesting just watching the set have
Microsoft using Windows but yes so uh so
I yeah this is actually the first time I
put my efficient change to the papac so
I'm moving to a nurse Maryland in June
dampen pets into Mouse so definitely I
think marking say I have done a lot of
sense that actually I haven't done
really a lot in calling a person so this
is the the first type of you know kind
of job that I trying to do something
ConAgra soon and so my title is the
quantum query complexity of entropy
estimation and I all explained that you
know if you don't feel that each word
make sense to you but hopefully someone
will make sense to you that you know
first of all I want you just to tell you
a little bit of why and do I come across
this problem of course if you just
search for entropy estimation it's a lot
of papers and the you see motivation
from universe just you know perspective
so it's an interesting primer on its own
right it's a fair enough but so my
motivation to you know to find this far
in the first place that I want you you
know fun in Oakland advantage in any
type of a person so this is a very very
first motivation and of course then you
see there there are lots of ranges of
potential averaging the classical
literature so this is really about
proper testing so we have starting a you
know poverty testing
classic literature especially nodded for
like big data and people want to see can
we use the sub linear time ask them to
test the property of in the huge data or
maybe the data could be a distribution
something like that and we're trying to
anything about using quantum tester but
still testing classical properties you
can use the quantum tester to test the
opponent property so a very important
example will be the quantum tomography
you just attach the state and as I said
this is a you know sub branch of proper
testing where you test of these two
additional properties it's not about a
function it's just about distribution
what kind of you know property
distribution has it's a well-motivated
branching the classical predatory
testing literature you know i show you
more applications in just in in a moment
and i you know particular reason I'm
interested in the distribution is
because it's not a boolean functions so
we have seen lots of instances starting
boolean function and you previously work
about a Kuantan in other one teacher for
sound you know learning or maybe testing
of boolean functions there you have a
very you know I think it's a closer
connection to what we have learning
quantum query compacity but this one is
about distributions so in the hope is
that is the my very new insight or call
for new techniques and that's why you
know I to use this one that's much at
that point okay so what's the problem
so I hope ever here is the gist in
familiar with entropy definition so just
after this anyway I you have a given
distribution and you can define the
Shannon entropy to be H P to be the
minus px log P X it carries a lot of you
know it is a very essential definition
encarcelado meaning information theory
first promoted by Shannon and that's why
from Shannon entropy and you can also
have a generalization of Oceanography
which is called or any entropy where
instead of you know having this
particular formula generator to be any
RFS or if it can be any real number I
mean you're in policy very number and
the definition will be if it's not one
which is defined to be
you know summation with px choose alpha
and Tagalog 1 and n times 1 over 1 minus
alpha if you take the limit you know to
the case one office one you know cards
with the definition of a channel entropy
and you know you're generating entropy
is the something you know has I think
more analytical and easy to work with
eg two tasks and a good to give you a
good approximation of HP and of course
they're in a certain a different you
know for different our theory has a you
know different other motivation just
starting this kind of running entropy as
well so just one one thing if you have
any questions feel free to interrupt me
my slides is not long so actually have
enough time okay so so what's the
problem
so let's assume your distribution is
supported on the 5n domain and the
question is that I if I have some you
know I can get some samples that you
know taking independently draw from this
description I want you estimate about
like either Shannon entropy or any
entropy within some you know error
merging with high probability so that's
that's the department so you'll give an
independent sample fun description you
want to estimate this entropy so as I
said this has a lot of motivation for
people to start a this kind of question
I won't you marry them that you can
finally to retain the statistic
information theory Learning Theory even
algorithm design so why a christian
design is the you know can be here is
because so maybe you're you're you know
in india major step of your algorithm
you're talking some distribution and
this entropy maybe just the sound you
know you know quality you can use to
tell you or distinguish between two
different cases and they want to have a
good estimation of that okay
now our question is of course is that we
want to find whether this any quantum
speed-up of decimation of Chanel and
Renny entropies the abdomen question and
say again
so this motivation is from you know we
have already started some quantum
property testing now we want to starting
the quantum testers for classical
property and this is for classical
distribution property so the first
literature on the topic is library
heroin had Hassidim that's the paper in
2011 so they discovered a quantum
speed-up for three very fundamental
tasks for you know in distribution of
harvard testing once called uniform
you're testing basic say if I have a
distribution whether it's close to Union
from distribution and the also banana
feed to say basically you do get a
supporter of to distribution without
serving or not and it's physical
difference basically you want to tell
the difference between two description
so you have the gift sample from two
different distributions and that's the
three tests they're you know that's how
come they haven't really worked on the
entropies so that's you know where we're
coming how I'll begin that speed of the
whole to this video because video other
than I mean this all is just a
polynomial speed-up so okay I so the
question is that what will be the
quantity that you know how large it is
so there'll be just a polynomial and I
think for those three problems just
chorionic yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a more general case this
is just a simple one yet you're right
yes so is there anything obvious about
the classical estimates for like to
entropy I mean or the I have a sample I
can generate and estimation ability
straightforward way right any estimate
of this several examples yeah I can
every job yeah every day to make out is
there anything else that that's a good
question no about about the classical
procedure also what's the procedure they
compare to uh I'll share a table for
that but that's a good question I this
review the question so so what you can
do category auditing you know
intuitively we have in a sample front
Xperia U might say just a numerically I
sorry empirically just looking to what
you did you know the fruit quiz
it says frequency and it guess what's
the probability and you know calculate
the assumption to define up that
probability you can do that that that's
not this way I mean even the classical
sitting yeah so classically I mean I
actually I put this after my thank you
slides which I probably well go there
it's just you have this question so
there many issues suggest using the
empirical estimator people call this as
imperative estimator so one reasons is
that you can think maybe for sound
property I don't need to get like full
information of a API you know the food
distribution so I can save a lot by just
using clever way of getting the
information now to getting every pie so
that's one possibility
so the other possibility is it's the you
know something wrong with the the
empirical estimator itself the reason is
that when you have the empirical your
expectation is the right thing but it's
the when you calculate like you may be
you know because it's like hours and
sampling hours and you want to say you
know laughter how many repetition I can
get into a good you know concentration
then that you don't have good
independence for HPI so if you think
about what you're getting perrolli and
the total sum of those frequency
be the total number of your samples if
you only have to impossibility if you
have one fixed for p1 then the other is
also fixed they're not independent so if
you directly use the empirical estimator
then you run into trouble because they
are not independent then when you
analyze the concentration then there's
correlation between different parts so
it's not that in a good because of this
and there's a way to fix that in a
classic award that I asked you whether I
have time to talk about to talk about
that it's not that directly relevant to
qu the quantum approach will take
priority but these guys are compared to
comparing to the state of the art yes
they dogs are the classical word yes
okay
no question
so what we have down so before just
talking about we have down so what's the
state of our art classical results and
here's the table so let's assume your
arrow I mean the error margin is
constant so just for simplicity
otherwise I need to write a lot of air
dependence I mean you're finding my
paper but probably not here so if you're
once you have to make Shannon entropy
the best you can get it's an over login
it's a might be a little bit spin why
you have an hour login you can imagine
this mummy end / but this is a actually
very competitive without that you see
why you have login I probably don't have
time to explain that but this is the
work is you know start first stem via
valiant brothers like the Georgia Valley
and the Paul value so I think George
Bennett has a 180 M dissertation for
just doing all this kind of stuff and if
you're interested just samples taken he
had a number of samples yeah and for the
the Reni entropy this is the best that
you can get so I think this is this year
soda and you see again for different
Ranger you have different you know
results so it fits between zero and one
you see this is a it always you know
there's a gap between the upper bound
and it's the lower bound it's not that
huge gap just to think about it so this
is a locket but this is like small one
small one it's not a huge gap but for
any are bigger than one is integer then
you have a note complete conversation
that's n to the 1 minus 1 alpha and for
any nine teachers in our further than
the star is the you know again become
complicated
I mean what's the absolute dependence so
usually well be like Polly 111 something
just an additional factory yeah okay so
this is a summary of so what we have
done so far
so I just think I didn't mention that
this is still ongoing work so I have
so maybe the picture where change if you
ask me in a mouse actually the picture
is not like this if you ask me you know
two weeks ago so I just telling you how
much you know my current status so it
skipping bobbing so basically and this I
is a table to show in a different
interval for those our files and this is
what we get as a result
and there's two particular I want to
help you look at this moment and I
didn't have a picture then you can maybe
it's easier to see the picture rather
than look at this so what the first
lines of an RF it's one that's the
Shannon entropy so what you get
classically it's a big sita n over log
in you can have quadratic speed up using
the you know the quantum method with
squared event that we only managed to
show a you know into the one third of
the lower bound so there's a big gap
between upper bound lower bound and when
are 5-2 so that's you know sometimes
call the collegian interview or in a
raining to entropy so classically you
have a complete castration that's
squared of n so why don't we can chew is
into the one-third and it is the camino
tidav and we have the matching lower
bound okay and what about the other
possible you know range of Arva here's
the picture so just let me explain
so this the neck the magnetite or the
Purple Line is the the what we can show
at the corner lower bound so this green
line is the classical bound we know for
most cases they it is tight so just to
consider this as the tide of classical
bound so the race line and a dots are
upper bounds so for the range you know
are ver between one half
- so we have always have some Cuong
advantage like this it's not always
quadratic you see here's the you know
the quadratic speed-up but not like you
know in other ranges and for you know
any are far bigger than 2 but not
integer we don't have any result at the
moment or you can I mean I talked more
about that but the situation that we do
have resulted that this is even worse
than classical ones so there's no need
to mention that and then when alpha is
the integer so classically you see this
the picture is a bit you know strange
you don't have like it continues
compacity for you know currently for
alpha but when offers the integer can do
significant better classically they're
like green dots and we can do even
better we have the the red dot so so
that's the current picture any questions
so far when you see you you cannot show
quantum advantage right for alpha
greater equals and - and non integer
right do you mean to say that you don't
have specific methods good there's a
lower bound seems to be better yeah the
lower one's better it could be because
we we we cannot approve better lower
bound no we don't have any way actually
we what we have is if you continue using
our algorithm you have some line you
know higher than the green line of
course you can say then I just use the
classical method then they can use the
classical a bounds as quantum upper
bound but that's not interesting and for
the purple line is yes that's the lower
bound we have and it could be because we
didn't you know get a very good lower
bound and we don't have any idea because
you see there's a huge gap between what
it can do category and what you can show
in s lower bound for content and the
this you know the star is complicated
for non-integer alpha so probably
something like I can come back later
I don't want you know complicated at the
moment
okay more questions
okay so for the techniques so what we
use to show into threes out so there's
the force you know the first thing is I
want to clarify actually we do have a
different type of a setup you know for
the standards you know the motor you're
talking about in the classical
literature and what you're going to use
in the content that I explained this is
a might be a reasonable set up and you
know comparables it up
so what see is the difference between
the set hab so what I'll card is like a
simple motor or the current model so in
this is actually the model proposed by
the bravia heron and the hex game paper
because they're the first one so the
motivation behind and before I really
you know define it I just want to say
what's motivation so think about you
know the catechol moto says you have
independent draws from some you know
dispersion so all you'll see I'll be
just at all the classical you know this
portion alone and if you want to say and
we want to have some corner the one
tidge you always think about you know we
can do like a super position or maybe
you know coherent sampling in that sense
now if you only you can only enjoy
depend on in front like a categories
portion that just well destroy this
possibility now we want to you know find
something can allow you to have a
coherent you know you know you know
coherent in or in the query or sample
from the distribution so getting
information in a coherent way and this
is one pretty good proposal so what is
it the proposal so instead of say you
get a distribution by you know simple
you know classical you know pets from
the some description you think you get
accept to the distribution by Oracle so
this article says you have impossibly
very much large you know the domain so
better you map to ends and it's a
supporter of a distribution so how can
you are you know define this Rho so it's
this by itself it's just a function it's
mapped from very large domain to your
support and the probability for HPI you
know
it's proportional to the size of the
preimage of this particular I add nerd
this you know Oracle function and I
divided by you know the total amount all
possibility or the size of your domain
so the P I will be just counts the
preimage of I and over F and you see
this in a well-defined distribution it's
not but if you define this way first you
see I mean this is easy to be a rational
number it's not be rational numbers
right but we you know can ignore dancing
you know the difference for now because
maybe for real applications we all have
a rational number to deal with you don't
have these Russian language to deal with
and so this is a proposal instead of
like having the sample you have this
Oracle to have any no to get information
from distribution so one simple think
you see from this definition is that if
I just sample uniformly from the the
domain and output the the you know the
Oracle apply on to the sample s so you
can recover what you know the the normal
like a sampling mode or you can get a
sample from this support and so this
direction is easy and in turns out they
can show at least in a classical setting
the reverse is also true so if you can
have the you know dude assembly no good
ain't no proper testing algorithm using
this Oracle and then you can manage you
to find a way just using the normal in a
sample model to achieve almost the same
you know simply no credit company so
this is the the non-trivial direction in
the classical work and the intuition
behind why this isn't serious because if
you just imagine you know what are the
ones which I can get by having this
amino Clara model rather than the
central model it's because you you see
I'm probably can use the the structure
of this Oracle function and they show
something like you can now really make
you the Oracle you know the structure of
alright
function so the intuition behind it is
that if I do any permutation over this f
its defined different article function
let it give you the same distribution so
your hours and making use of this outer
function should output the exact same
thing so guess what quanta review said
one of the Oracle interfering is it for
any Oracle or there exists an Oracle
that is it aiming ah do we need to find
a specific work of two dimensionally the
usual so it's true for any Oracle we can
come from yeah the the question is that
what's the the qualifier for the the
article and the answer is that it just
need to give me any article give you the
right distribution you haven't seen each
work for that Oracle yeah so this Erica
Larson work for all articles giving this
distribution and that's important and if
we have that you say you have all the
permutation then you can somehow you
know do a random permutation before you
do the real function is the real agram
using the article then you can show you
know if you want to do that and because
we don't have any limitation on the size
of s then in a Rapids it says you is
announced you just do a random sample
uniform sample for ads and output this
so it's a cute argument and but it shows
you the classic award there into
something okay so then you know we don't
know how to you know get a quantum
generator for the sampling model but for
our komodo that that's easy
so you just say okay we have coherent
just query of this Oracle model now then
they becomes possible we can do
something you know better than classical
and making you the coherent query so
that's so that's the model we use
the applications of this will sure you
really have a source you can push a
button and draw down I get a bunch of
files on the compressed data can I use
it obvious how to construct such an
Oracle in such a such a case you mean
apartment needs you in your say how can
you construct this Opie from P but
that's probably love freedom in there I
guess yeah yeah yeah like a canonical we
like it well I mean if you know the you
know P and you know they're all rational
numbers and this should be some simple
construction give you once in the pasta
Oracle I just don't know if they have
other like a requirement like this need
to be efficient or no yeah I mean I
don't know I mean I'm that's a good
question I haven't thought about it okay
so yeah this is a continent Oracle model
I'm consciously now I want to just give
you some like in a high-level idea how
we had you know do for you know and give
some coin at the Wantage it turns out we
need to use different ideas for
different and range of you know you know
alpha and this is actually same thing as
Haskell word as well so and for
different offer you know the Deranian
tribute compare meters and and when our
first one is China entropy so um you can
see a dear dear you know they use a
different idea and there's some
advantage and this other one ditch and
it connects you in all kinds of
different you know stuff so might be
interesting you know because there's
kind of connection so on the first one
will be what how I get you know point
advantage for the parameter range
between 1/2 and it to and this is any RF
another just in Java the same in Arafah
so I think you know for this community
we already know amplitude amplification
and v information so I'm going to talk
about that but there's a two in a more
direct component we're going to use in
algorithm so one is the quantum speed-up
of the chebyshev in counting the chip
chip and counter here refer to the chip
chef and colleague for the concentration
major you where you know the expectation
you know the the variance and you just
count how many copies to do you have you
know just graphically London you
repeated multiple times you can have a
good arrow bound so it turns out there's
a you know quantum speed ad for this
kind of procedure and this is worked by
Ashley Montano and give it like a
quadratic speed-up of championship and
quality and concentration of major so
what's the set hub so the city obvious
that assume we have the unicorn Alison
the Kona accent and of course if you
have a category algorithm we just need
to make it reversible and count upon
Alison and other puts of random variable
X and you know about the variance and it
turns out you can use like you know Big
O Tara of the the variance square over
the absol of both algorithm and the
reverse of Agra so then you can have a
good estimate effects of its expectation
with let's say the the arrow of the
epsilon and the chance will be a success
chance will be like 3/4 Sigma is this
kind of errands yeah Sigma here stem
reverenced absolutes the arrow so so
arrow Absalom you know biscuit says in
this year's for the additive arrow here
for the multi particular arrow to
absence Stanford arrow and the Sigma
stem for the centre variance and the the
band will be big head of Sigma or wrap
zone so what you want to compare two is
that the classical a if you use the
championship in quality you need to use
Sigma square of absolute school well of
course there you don't have you don't
need to use the inverse of there because
my not be reversible so so that's the
one of the tool we use and the intuition
behind you know doing this is the you
know coming from amplitude amplification
but I think this is very nice the you
know you know packaging of the
techniques
okay so that's that's one tool we're
going to use is where a and B universe
could have significantly different cost
because of it because here it's just we
only can consider the query capacity so
okay you're here you're thinking so I
think usually you know like the circuit
if for a and if it's quantum adjuster
run you know cleaner reversely than the
same cost and this might be a kiss when
you need to have only half the classical
a it makes it reversible first but still
in that case maybe you can run you still
need to have a reversibility and a
inverse so this part will still have the
same come passing yeah yeah yeah
there shouldn't be too much over again
because some functions graphically they
have a simple circuit but the inverse
has a very complicated circuit right
like it one bit
yeah yeah I either didn't have condition
up I'm shaking this yeah yeah yeah I
mean we assume you can find the you know
simple circuit for a and it's a it's a
reversible circuit then just to reverse
itself so maybe if you have a classical
one one function it's finding the
reversible computational functions hard
yeah but after you find it reversal is
you need to do yeah okay now the second
tool second to it's actually more
standard just we use the quantum
counting and so basically you imagine
you have specific you know function
you know fronted domain attitude 0 1 and
want to count pre-image of the Roger or
what so the reason I you know this is
just if I open the back box to see what
will be the out of the distribution for
for like it for each possibility and I
open this acid just because you know
later on we're show we do need to make
use of this or you cannot use this you
know the Khan Academy at a black box
so for the analysis for for now you can
just forget about it and you know
particular trick we're going to use is
that we
the cetera we want to find the
estimation of the distribution and if I
want to find description in estimation
for P i we can just directly use the
quantum counting we just put everything
other than I to be zero and everything
is I it should be one so if I count it I
only get to the number of inner
perimeter to the you know particular
output I and I divided by the I get
estimation with the P I so that's the
way of getting okay so so that's you are
component so what's the real algorithm
the reaction is something like this so
we have a framework to estimate any any
like quantity that is Sigma Y P I and F
P I so f can be any function any
function in from 0 1 to a real number
and this is just to give you a sense if
the frf excess of minus log X this is
Jenna entropy is X to the RF minus 1 so
this is the running entropy so that's a
unified framework but for NSS you need
to do a lot different since the
framework is a unifying okay so so what
I'm going to so this is the outline of a
person it's actually quite intuitive so
what you we do is down with first to go
you know first you know this is what we
this subroutine we use and the meaning
of a subroutine just to get estimate of
a P I and get estimate then get the
athlean of FBI and then you randomly
pick this i you know as the the men up
you know algorithm so the expectation of
what I get from the subroutine will be
just you know recover exactly this is
Sigma ipi FBI so the way we get the TI
is that you do the counting quantum
count you know counting to get to the
preimage of our to have the estimate of
a pi then you just do actually calculate
at this F function based on that and in
terms of that together you give it a VIP
I and then you know
because I rent an example I from this
distribution you can easily do that just
to classical you can do that you know
just uniformly to the you know a uniform
of or as to ensure the article function
so if you call this subroutine multiple
times what you end up with will be
expectation for what you get a
subroutine while being exactly FBI and
then we make use of the Qantas speed of
the ship shipping quality so you can be
at you know if you don't use this to be
that we probably need to use like a
Sigma square over epsilon square and
numbers of this sub 14 but because
there's to be a is going to use a
Sigma or Rabson so that's a general
framework and you can see if I want you
in a get a good in a band for you know
specific function of F so there are a
few things I need to do so first I need
you you know calculate what's the
expectation and calculate what's the
variance and you know from those two
things I can also I need to calculate
you know we're you know oh sorry so why
I need to calculate to the expectation
other than just the intuitive thing
that's the right thing because there are
arrows even happen for a chest up so
when I say you are think this is the
quantum counting you get in a pie but
this is not exactly this case so their
dick they could be arrows so you need to
calculate expectation as well but I mean
other than that the you know there's
nothing more you need to do your
question okay
okay so so just show a demonstrator with
specific example for the channel entropy
we need to do this again for the
calculating the expectation and the
reason we want to do that is that we
want to show achieved on expectation the
one you get it from the subroutine the
it matches the Shannon entropy but
because you could have arrow in your
estimation of P I and when you have P I
very close to zero this log p is very
very sensitive so so that's a best place
we need to special you know you know
attention and so the way we deal with
that is as I said just to open the
blocks for counting counting you need to
know what will be the tail bound for the
arrows and you do a very rare through
analysis then you can show I mean
there's a wage bounty of the arrow for
expectation it's it's boring it's not
that interesting that incident you know
important you should have that you you
know make sure you have crack knees so
but you have the high level picture I
don't want you just this you know for
you with this detailed company
calculation so for shannon entropy
estimation so this is the way we
specifically choose the parameter and
because the channel just choose the -
block it's just following the exactly
same framework as I said the calculation
for expectation is actually non-trivial
- because so it can be tell you know
arrow and this is very sensitive and
there's a another calculation that's
important is to calculate the variance
so internal infer the variance to attend
0 we need to again this is a this might
be standard in information theory that
I'm not sure how how in a Halle war how
complicated this kind of technique is
use of in quantum setting because you
can see here we have you know errors in
HPI then we want to use this
pi2 are in a calculated the entropy and
all the errors can just approve or gated
industry all the steps and here you
consider the variance that's like second
momentum so it can be more complicated
just imagine that so what I can tell you
the calculation take a few pages just to
do that maybe on this slides I just tell
you the final result is you get
something like this you know making it
so the framework making through the
calculation and it you can get square
root of n over epsilon square so that's
the casinos precise dependence on the
episode okay so that's for the channel
entropy okay
the star for the Reni entropy at you
know for just parameter range it's also
senator it's just getting more
complicated and I mean the calculation
it's that let me see whether I have the
specific no I don't even have that sorry
I should show you the dependence but
this is I think this is roughly the
dependency can see this is the only have
1 over epsilon here for for you know
case Arfa between 1/2 and 2 but not
equal to 1 okay so so that's the big
framework for this rate you know
parameter range and this just show you
some calculation sketch of this idea now
let's turn to another parameter range
it's maybe just you know this is a
totally new you know a totally different
framework so um so the the this kind of
emitter range is the RF is bigger than -
that's integer Isis a I we don't know
how to do for the case offers we get
into not integer that's for the into
integer case so why we have the solution
so the the reason is that it is also
observed in the console literature when
our first integer we this department you
to have a good in an empirical estimator
based on the RFS for increase any moment
so what's the frequency moment just
imagine you have a sequence of you know
numbers coming from the you know support
N and you can't occurrence over the you
know each one to n you know the number
of those are curious I can't m12 MN
the capital M and in there difference in
so capital M can be much much larger
than so this is also standard said
having the first the streaming algorithm
people want to capture the frequency
moments so the frequency moments for you
know case forgets moments which FK it
should be mi to the K and sum over alpha
okay so why this is a relevant if we
just use the empirical estimation for
rent entropy for any artha so we are
actually calculating this so sigma i of
salvation over ipi to the alpha and this
is the one this is the just the you know
increase say this empirical estimation
just you know replace p AI by two you
know the frequency over the total number
of M so the mi over m and it just you
know you get m to the K out
so that's FK / MK oh I sorry I actually
actually actually use K here or you can
easy this should be RFI here okay so so
basically this observation says if I
want you to get to integer you know
renting entropy for you know larger than
two it's actually I just need to
calculate the you know the frequency
moment in some sense so so you know what
classically are people does for this
kind of you know empirical estimator it
just renders central multiple copies so
you can sing the competitive of the M
and you can use this after your
estimator to say you know after cm you
can just account m1 m2 MN and you know
use this as your estimator of the the
final solution again I said this is now
the the best akafuku estimator because
so they're issues like they're not you
know mutually independent you know the
way you do the concentration of major
you need to calculate variance in your
have trouble there so this roughly uh
yes work one case Multi message
yeah that that's correct the this
plumber also works when K is not integer
the the reason why we we need to have
this you know constraints that is we
only know when case integer how should
calculators efficiently
yeah yeah but of course this is true for
it cannot be integer and it's actually
good question I don't know how to do for
non integer K select indicators of
different offices different structurally
to calculate or things like it house it
was it does it not to measure different
things then I have no idea what they're
any entropy or not we're feeling what it
really does all right
I'm sorry can just case you've changed
it all four different else's like your
calculation when you what your hope will
have to be very different yeah continues
this is there any entropy to put to
measure something like concept it's kind
of like the same for difficult office so
I think this is also the question is
that why I think this goes back to why
we started different or any entropy if
the calculation is so different okay
okay I mean so maybe I let me give you a
simple answer if you say the rainy on
trapeze three and a three point one they
actually measure something similar to
each other it just we are clever enough
to do the case for three we're not
clearing up to the three point one yeah
yeah with a measuring is equivalent but
you can get bounds on these three cases
you can't get to know anything I'll say
first I think it's more about that the
algorithm we can do it's like yeah yeah
it's like we have limited to to deal
with the integer case yeah classical you
can do 900 case and you see the picture
but just you know we don't know how to
get cone at one edge over that yeah
okay so so we want to basically use this
empirical estimator in the knotting the
sample model in the query model so so
there are certain you know a few issues
that I just want to highlight a two
issue so the first is that you can now
to query them times so what a classic
you do just aquarium M times answer
simple M times and use the empirical
estimator if you do the Attic you and
when you correct I'm pleased to have
there's no other one tidge and how can
you do that it turns out there's a you
know observation we have is that if you
have the corner article so and you're
not treating article that's the way we
define it but just think the article is
just a sequence of samples as we usually
see the domain you have and then you
calculate our frequency of this you know
the article applied to the one you know
- and here the size of the domain is it
exactly give you the edge to the artha
times that this is in other words it's
another for increasing moments but not
over you know a M this is over F so as
it can be very very large
but because s is now ready the number of
queries you make is just the size of
your you know domain of your Oracle
function your physical it used to be
as it's the I mean this as is the the
domain of the Oracle function so I think
I think this is a consistent so I only
use as for the domain of the it's a
communality over there where the hacker
right before the song should be a number
yeah this is counting on it yeah yeah
yeah oh okay I see it
it is the coming out this is number this
is every to the size of excitedly okay
so so basically if we can you know run
the opera in a frequency of you know a
verse em on our corner Oracle you know
and alpide then we can give this and get
this you almost get you know this part
because you know ass now we can do that
and actually you can find a quantum
speed-up this again Ashley's work and we
actually has many good works to
calculate this our preferred gets moment
and with better than classical quick
complexity and so just give you ideas so
classically bets can do to calculate
alpha for crazy moments should be n to
the 1 minus 1 over alpha it can do in a
small industry to the for 1 minus 1 of
alpha so this is not known to be the
best you know what you can do in the
quantum world but still it's already
better than classical and you know why
we can do that it turns out we can have
this kind of problem you know reduce the
offer frequency moment the two there are
four distinct in its program and we know
for our four distinct in it's probably
there is to achieve the state of our -
you know quantum algorithms by Alexander
pelops
using the learning graph and that's why
you have this small over you know n to
the 3/4 because the the real number is
very complicated so I didn't want to put
this on the five but you see there if
you have the you know improvement on
best thing you
have improvement on this capacity we
don't know whether that's the best I can
do at the moment so there's a cache the
cache is that I said that this is your
in the cabinet he'll figure you know the
domain for your oracle function so if
you just think about that
so f should be the number of you have in
a sampled in the calculation of your
frequency moment of progress so so that
this is the imprecise end it's not
really n it should be asked so you know
cost of travel because when you compare
it in but if you using this approach
this part should be s now there's a
simple solution to that it turns out we
just need to choose as to be our end so
that is sufficient to you know make
everything go through for the analysis
so R has its counseling here so just you
know this is roughly just n but you see
there the considers you know conceptual
gap and this conceptual gap is somehow
important and when we consider now to
any integer alpha and so something I'm
part of mission at the end of this might
might talk but that's the idea you can
just choose F subi RN then you have you
know corners PDF for any bigger than two
integer alpha okay so all a versa you
know just a mission from the lower bound
will get so we get a three set of lower
bound and that you know continuously you
put them together give you the quantity
over bound of the entire parameter range
so how we get them we use reductions and
there's three reduction we make use of
so the first one is that if there's a
result by Aaronson and Benes fish a
there should be some polynomial relation
between contact the classic complexity
if you want you started a function where
if you run in permitting you input the
result does not change so and that's the
way we give this a lower bound because
we know the classical a lower bound then
we know that you know the connect the
content of about and the second one
coming from the collegian and it's not
very hard to tree embedding into this
it's probably because you have different
religion than you can see the entropy
can differ by artists account amount
this is the sir ones by having with the
province system I think this is like in
a refined version of occlusion in some
sense so it gets give you a you know
good about wearing a large parameter
range so that's just an overview of what
I get for the lower bound okay so yeah I
still have two minutes I want to talk
already talked about this self in
questions and I'm going work so I think
this is a message I want to send and you
see we have some quantum speed-up for
different you know parameter n 0 for
alpha and I actually I you know I keep
asking myself this question
so while is this you know Colonel work
you know is this right or you know in
the framework is to say it's not that
satisfactory you see the pictures it's
not you know it's complicated I should
say you don't you need to have a piece
wide solution for the you know hole in a
parameter range can you do better than
that
and so we don't know whether you know
you can use the adder alternative at the
moment and we are not satisfied with the
current framework but that's the best
thing we can show you at the moment and
we do know if there's some natural
attempts that do not work
unfortunately I mean I'm very
unfortunate this is the only the thing
we found that works that's not a
satisfactory and if you have thoughts or
ideas we can talk about it I said it's
still ongoing so maybe if you ask me the
question is I'm questioning those three
weeks and made me change my mind so I
don't know so of course what we want to
do we want to do this for any author in
the whole parameter range not just the
integer we have some solution for this
as I said again you can you know use
this solution and it you know just for
any offer you just don't have any
quantity one page of an offer it's
bigger than two
so but we do have the classical
resulting that you know range so maybe
you can you know just make clever you
know you know a quantum algorithm for
that parameter range that's possible so
there's something I mean a concrete I
can say and I'm going to work so we do
you know think about the case when our
efforts in infinity so what methods
infinity the rainy infinity norm is also
called a being entropy so me entropy
basically what you want to do is find
the maximum probability maximum of the P
I so and this is a country say if you
have the you know a sequence of items
you want to find the one that occurred
person the most enough time so
classically again this is interesting
you have n over log n so this is not
already starting in the literature but
it's not the heart if you follow the
valiant browsers just here and we do the
calculation for this Purdue case you can
get to read out and we can have a square
root of N quantum over them so that's
what something we knew and we all can we
can also connect this carbon to the are
four distinct in its program similar to
what we have done for the you know the
integer alpha case but now for this you
know the in the entropy you need to have
a super constant alpha so super counsel
are four distinct new Department is
actually a total open question for even
for content and we know classically wow
you can do that and why is is totally
I'll know it because so they're only two
or we Delta for there are four distinct
is problems I mean upper bound you can
see the very original the algorithm by
Aventis
the state of art is our estimation by
the Alexander Belov and if you put super
constant R into their firm work either
getting any other vantage
they only work for counseling Arthur I
mean that is for gloves the only for
content offer for a Bennis work you can
get for like a square root of a login
because you can still have the advantage
that go beyond that even have an
advantage so we need like a log in this
thing is so if we're directly apply that
there's no advantage yes
the question was the secrets of simple
constants anything bigger than constant
it's like you know have a dependence
iron yeah maybe I should say super
polynomial then you see the super
polynomial now just super constant yeah
have you know any dependents name that's
super constant okay so I think this
question by itself is interesting I you
know given the distinct it's probably
important and this just started in a
different parameter range
what do you looking to do we we don't
know the result the moment but I think
there's Stephanie is a question in
interest on in survive alright and it's
one more thing I want to mention that so
so far all the lower bounds are obtained
by reductions so in the reduction from
the hard building function progress but
this department is actually just about
distributions can we have direct angle
you know develop tools should directly
handle this case maybe we can have a
popular method of for dispersions now if
we're just putting functions and then
you can hope to prove that a lower bound
as I said II there's in our lower bound
is going to be you know there's a gap
between rotting into category with but
maybe that's because we're we're not
good at proving lower bound for this
type of questions so yeah this actually
this is you know just reflect my very
initial purpose and we my starting the
problem that can in call for new
techniques I think this is a you know a
concrete one that needs a new type of
techniques and that's it thank you
[Applause]
the owner is officially yes basically
yeah yeah so so it's like the
relationship should be signed this way
so in the classical word Oracle model
and the cut sample model there somehow
equivalent and when you extend it to
true Contin where you can only show a
quantity Wantage in the Oracle model
because there's a simple extension can
allow coherent query of you know
coherent access of the information with
distribution in the query I don't know
so I mean to be fair I mean most naive
approach might be
yeah but I think the issue is that if
you think about the sample world then
you have a lot of the distribution
that's like diagonal density operator
tensor so the question is that how can
you do that and you want to use quantum
so because Eris is diagnosed then in the
if you want your one corner of the 1 kg
my singing I need to have some latitude
in superposition but where you can have
superposition that that's the question I
I know I don't really have a good idea
to see how can you make use of you know
the diagonal matrix and again make it
super position the the desk root
question I mean definitely I want you
see whether it's possible again you just
use it give some other longitudes in the
world but I don't haven't got commas on
that I guess I mean there there action
not many literature already and I one
reason that I guess it's like actually I
try to sample model first so I mean I
cannot put the since I try to say that
in my slides but I can tell you I tried
that I tried that like for one to mouth
I even try to think whether I can use
the you know the exponential
distillation method I think that's like
in very beautiful technique then in all
the since I know I tried and don't see
any advantage because I think the
divisions that what whenever you do is
and that you don't really make use of
content if you only start with the you
know diagonal yeah this is
sympathetically knowledge is you know
use classical way to simulate what are
you doing the quantum then if this
shouldn't be any advantage because
you're just in practical
I have another question at the very end
you mentioned in the open problems it's
basically the lower bounds are obtained
by reductions to - no another problem
yeah
have you tried to apply the like
adversary' method to that specific
problem and I sampling problems yeah
yeah that's a good question so so
applying other words for messages on our
schedule for next week but we do applied
upon automatic so I can tell you a
little bit so I mentioned this this
lower bound square root of n for me
entropy so that's a by reduction and
it's not satisfactory but you can see
the damper bounce n over log n so it's
also hard to see you can get a you know
bound for n over log n you know from you
know the normal way you prove lower
bound so so so what we do is that we say
how about we just directly looking to
the polynomial generated and think about
a worst case for the me entropy and it
should see what we did agree bound you
can get front edge and ten turns out
this in order to do that you need to use
the lower bound you know for the
collegian you know the tickets there to
think how you can because for
multivariable polynomials we don't know
a lot of technique to deal with that so
you want to have some way to make it in
a similar type sense to become a single
variable and if we just use that
technique along that's not include
anything better than squared event but
it could kill I mean it could because
just a we're not a clever enough
so yeah it's similar to two collision as
I should say the techniques techniques
wise you know similar yeah and you can
you can you know just because a we're
constructing some you know polynomials
okay I think we should wrap it up yeah
yeah thank you
how do you get okay okay you thank you